6-Need English from BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Neil.
And I'm Beth. There's a famous English saying, a friend in need is a friend indeed. And it's
true. Everyone needs friends to share life's ups and downs. Do you have many friends, Neil?
Yes, I have some close friends, but maybe not as many as I'd like.
That's interesting, because often it's women who have many friends, while men find it harder
to maintain strong friendships, especially as they get older. In fact, according to one
recent survey, only 27% of British men say they have at least six close friends.
So is it true that men find it difficult to make friends? We'll be hearing from Max Dickens,
author of a book on male friendship called Billy No Mates. And as usual, we'll be learning
some useful new vocabulary as well.
But first, I have a question for you. We know that place friends are important, not just
for having fun, but for good mental health as well. So according to research by Oxford
University's Institute of Cognitive Anthropology, how many close friends do we need for our
mental well-being? Is it A, 5, B, 10 or C, 20?
I'll say we need at least five close friends.
Okay, Neil. I'll reveal the answer at the end of the programme. Now, however many
friends you have, it's a stereotype that women are better than men at making and keeping
close friends. Here's Claudia Hammond outlining the problem for BBC Radio 4 programme all
in the mind.
Now, when times are tough, friends are often the people who get us through who are there
to listen to reassure, maybe to advise us if that's what we want. So why do we sometimes
find it hard to make friends? Although the friends we used to have seem to have somehow
drifted away. Now, there is an idea that women are much better at maintaining their friendships
and that men are more likely to hang out with whoever is around rather than to nurture
those relationships. And we were wondering whether this was really true or is that just
a stereotype.
Claudia uses the phrase times are tough to describe a situation of trouble, unhappiness or
financial difficulty. Friends help us get through these difficult periods of life. The
phrasal verb get through has several meanings, but here it means manage to live through an
unpleasant period of time.
The problem may be that your friends have drifted away, gradually moved further and further
away until your connection with them has broken. And it seems that's especially true
for men.
That's right, when author Max Dickens was getting married, he realised he didn't have
any close male friends he could ask to be his best man, the person who helps the groom
at a wedding. This led him to write the book Billy No Mates looking at why he didn't have
any close male friends. Here's Claudia Hammond again talking with Max for BBC Radio 4 program
all in the mind.
And Max, it's interesting that you kind of went public on this if you like. Your book
is even called Billy No Mates, the very thing that a lot of us would dread being. It can't
have been easy to decide to say this publicly anyway.
No, it's a real double edshaw being the face of a book called Billy No Mates, I've got
to say. But I think, so loneliness doesn't look like me. I'm in my early to mid 30s, I'm
pretty outgoing, I'm quick to buy my round. It shouldn't look like me, but increasingly
it does. So loneliness isn't just the elderly anymore, it's younger people.
Max called his book Billy No Mates, slang for a person with no friends. It's a memorable
book title, but Max says being the public face of a book called Billy No Mates is a double
edged sword, something with unfavorable as well as favourable consequences.
In fact, Max doesn't look like someone with no friends, he's young, generous and outgoing,
and adjective describing someone who's friendly and enjoys meeting people. But increasingly,
loneliness is affecting younger men, thanks partly to social media, which can make it
seem as though everyone is having a great time with their mates, except you.
Max thinks the answer is getting out and meeting people in third spaces, places like sports
clubs or reading groups, which are separate from either home or work.
All of which helps get closer to the magical number of friends needed for good mental
health. I think it's time you revealed the answer to your question, Beth.
Yes, I asked how many close friends we need for our mental wellbeing. You said it was
five, which was the correct answer. According to Oxford University's Professor Robin Dunbar,
we need a core circle of five close friends. Plus a wider support network of about ten,
making a total number of fifteen friends for good mental health.
Okay, let's recap the vocabulary from the programme, starting with the phrase times our
tough, which describes periods of trouble or difficulty in life.
If you get through something, you manage to live through a difficult situation.
To drift away means to gradually move further apart from someone until your relationship
with them eventually ends.
Clearly no mate is slang for someone who has no friends.
A double-edged sword describes something with unfavorable as well as favourable consequences.
And finally, the adjective outgoing describes someone who is very friendly and enjoys talking
to people.
Once again, our six minutes are up. Goodbye for now.
Bye.
Six-Mate English from BBCLearningEnglish.com